aquí tenemos otro ejercicio muy parecido
al ejercicio que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado estábamos hablando acerca del
comportamiento de los extremos y este
ejercicio es muy parecido de hecho creo
que ésta nos va a servir más para
entender el comportamiento de los
extremos porque si te das cuenta aquí
tengo gráficas locas realmente muy locas
y yo lo que quiero encontrar es cuál de
los siguientes polinomios cuál de las
siguientes funciones equivale a estas
gráficas para eso voy a tratar de
utilizar la información que me da el
comportamiento en los extremos así que
empecemos con la primera vamos a empezar
con esta de aquí ok y dice que es igual
a todo esto que te parece si de igual
manera que en el vídeo pasado nos
fijamos primero en qué es lo que pasa
con el término más grande con el término
en x que tiene el grado mayor entonces
esto lo quedaría como ye yé es igual a
menos 1 sobre 11 no olvidemos la
constante y si te das cuenta el término
más grande sale de multiplicar cada uno
de los términos más grande
los paréntesis es decir aquí tengo x
aquí tengo a x cuadrada de aquí tengo a
x cuadrada son los términos más grandes
de cada uno de los paréntesis así que
vamos a multiplicar los y así vamos a
encontrar el grado más grande de esta
función que tengo aquí y bueno para esto
x por equis cuadradas x cúbica porque es
cuadrada es x quinta es decir que esta
función tiene como término máximo x
quinta tiene como grado máximo el 5 ok y
bueno y es igual a menos un onceavo
sobre x quinta y si te das cuenta en
todos los demás van a estar por aquí no
los voy a apuntar porque me da mucha
flojera de hacer todas estas operaciones
de aquí y el vídeo sería eterno y lo que
quiero que veas es qué va a pasar con el
último el último de estos términos y si
te das cuenta el último de los términos
lo voy a encontrar multiplicando 1 sobre
11 este de aquí por el más pequeño de
cada uno de los paréntesis que es este 5
este 10 y este 2 x aunque tenga 2x va a
ser el último de estos términos y esto
me quedaría
menos por menos más por más por más es
más más un onceavo por 55 ciervos x 1050
onceavos por 2x es 100 100 sobre 11
ok y bueno a ver si nos sirve esta parte
de aquí lo que quiero que veas es que
cuando tengo que igual a menos 1 sobre
11 x quinta y todo lo demás en este
momento te puedes dar cuenta que el
coeficiente que está al lado de la equis
quinta es negativo y entonces tú me
puedes decir que esta gráfica se va a
comportar en los extremos va a tener un
comportamiento los extremos muy parecido
a equis cúbica a menos x kubica porque
aquí tenemos algo negativo y vamos a
ponerlo aquí el comportamiento con x
en los extremos en los extremos extremos
se aparecen se parece a menos x cúbica y
menos x cúbica es una función que
podemos saber cómo se ve su
comportamiento de los extremos recuerda
que cuando esto es algo muy negativo
cuando lo llevo al cubo me da algo muy
negativo y entonces x menos me va a dar
algo positivo se va a ver algo más o
menos así ok y después
va a pasar algo por aquí realmente no me
interesa mucho saber qué es lo que va a
pasar justo en medio pero lo que sí
quiero que veas es que cuando tenemos
algo muy pero muy positivo si lo llevo
al cubo me da algo muy positivo y cuando
lo multiplicó por menos se vuelve algo
muy negativo así que más o menos se va a
ver así la gráfica de menos x cúbica y
está esta función que tengo aquí como
tiene un grado impar es decir 5 y tiene
aquí al lado de x quinta este
coeficiente negativo su comportamiento
va a ser muy parecido es decir estamos
buscando
y cam que cuando x tome valores muy
negativos que sea muy positivo y que
cuando x tome a valores muy positivos ya
sea muy negativo y si te das cuenta que
f va bajando vamos bien vamos bien sube
baja y después otra vez sube por lo
tanto f no es la gráfica de esta función
es más podemos decir que f es la gráfica
de una función cuyo grado máximo sea par
porque así se comportan las funciones
cuyo grado máximo sea par ok si nos
fijamos ahora en g que empieza al revés
por lo tanto no va a hacer
empieza subiendo después baja después
sube después otra vez v por lo tanto gtx
no es creo que la única que nos queda es
hdx ok me está fallando la vista ésta de
aquí es hdx hdx y vamos a ver si
realmente me funciona empieza a bajar
empieza a bajar empieza a bajar después
sube después va acá después sube después
baja y es más o menos el comportamiento
de esta x cúbica por lo tanto ya puedo
decir que utilizando el comportamiento
de los extremos que es justo esto que
aquí suben
ok más o menos así perfecto y además que
aquí baja ok que equipaje ok puedo decir
que la gráfica que representa a esta
función
de igual a menos 1 sobre 11 x quinta
además todo lo demás es hdx esta de aquí
ya no tengo miedo de decir que es hd x
ok y además bueno hay otras formas de
verlo otra forma de verlo es que cruza
al eje las equis una dos tres cuatro
cinco veces y en este caso que es la
única que cruza el eje de las equis
cinco veces podríamos concluir que es x
quinta pero no me gusta mucho concluir
este tipo de cosas utilizando esa
información o también que pasa por el
cero si todo si x vale cero todo esto se
va a ser cero y entonces pasaría por el
origen sin embargo las tres pasan por el
origen así que no creo que tampoco nos
sirva mucho para concluir creo que la
mejor forma de concluir en este momento
es utilizando el comportamiento los
extremos como se parece al menos x
cúbica entonces ésta
esta función de grado quinto que tengo
aquí tiene un comportamiento a x cúbica
en los extremos por lo tanto ya está
aquí tengo el primero
el primero es hdx y es una buena forma
de concluir vamos a intentar hacer la
segunda así que vamos a quitar esto de
aquí no me gusta este de aquí me va a
ser mucho
espacio y yo lo que necesito ese espacio
ya no vamos a trabajar con la siguiente
y para eso déjame tomar este color y
dejarme tomar a esta herramienta yo
quiero ver qué es lo que va a pasar con
esta de aquí
es igual y de igual manera vamos a
calcular cuál es el máximo de los
términos de esta función y para eso lo
que voy a hacer es no olvidar este
undécimo ok y después lo voy a
multiplicar por el más grande que de
cada uno de los paréntesis que en este
caso es x cuadrada y x cuadrada por lo
tanto 10 se vería de la forma un 10º 11º
de x cuarta más todos los demás y bueno
como sabemos que las tres cruzan aquí en
el origen entonces no es necesario
calcular todos los demás lo es
lo que es importante es fijarnos en el
coeficiente que está al lado del término
mayor que en este caso es un décimo que
por cierto es un valor positivo por lo
tanto como tenemos un término x cuarta
que tiene un grado par entonces podemos
decir que el comportamiento de los
extremos se parece se parece
a equis cuadrada y x cuadrada es una
parábola que hable hacia arriba por lo
tanto se va a ver más o menos así cuando
x sea muy negativa esto me va a quedar
algo positivo algo va a pasar aquí no sé
que sea lo que pase pero después cuando
x sea positiva también voy a obtener una
positiva entonces se tiene que ver algo
así y si te das cuenta
efe cumplía eso efe tiene un
comportamiento de los extremos muy
parecidos aquí tenemos una parte en
positiva ok sube y aquí también tenemos
una parte en positiva es decir también
va para arriba tenemos valores muy pero
muy pero muy grandes y por lo tanto
podemos concluir que esta función de
aquí su gráfica es fx es f de equis y ya
sin miedo a equivocarnos otra forma de
ver eso es que aquí tenemos una dos tres
cuatro raíces pero recuerda que hay que
tener cuidado a lo más tenemos cuatro
raíces pero no forzosamente debemos de
tener
4 ok fx y bueno esta de aquí ya sabemos
que es que de equis pero de todas
maneras vamos a probar que en efecto que
me quede que sea gdx así que vamos a
quitar esta parte de aquí
muestra aquí quiero quitar esta parte de
aquí ok y vamos a poner la última y
vamos a hacer algo muy parecido me voy a
fijar en el término más grande que yo
encuentre que en este caso es que es
igual a 1 sobre 11 1 sobre 11 x por
equis cuadrada por x cuadrada me queda x
quinta ok también es una función de
grado 5 más todos los demás más todos
los demás pero ahora lo que quiero que
veas es que tenemos un coeficiente al
lado de la x quinta en positivo por lo
tanto se va a ver algo contrario a menos
x kubica se va a aparecer se parece
parece a x kubica
positivo y bueno en la gráfica de x
cúbica positivo tiene algo más o menos
así primero primero toma valores muy
negativos después algo pasa y después
toma valores muy pero muy positivos
entonces vamos a buscar lo que se
asemeja a esto y si te das cuenta es que
de x que de x toma aquí primero un valor
muy pero muy pero muy negativo ok
algo así y después va
para acabar acaba para acá y al final el
comportamiento final es algo muy pero
muy pero muy positivo y entonces ya
puedo decir que estoy bien me siento
bastante seguro de que esto tenga toda
la razón está de aquí sea gtx que es la
última que me faltaba
además acabo de corroborar que todo está
bien que todo es consistente y ya tengo
resuelto el ejercicio todo gracias al
comportamiento en los extremos